hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game uh from the 2021 feed
hs.com grand swiss it's about his
girlfriend versus sergey monsession and
it's one of the games you guys have
requested the most it's uh not from
round 11 it's actually from round eight
but you know the game is just crazy the
game features five queens you know not
two or three or four but actually five
queens uh and it's incredibly short and
that makes it uh all the
uh all the more impressive but before we
check out the game as the tournament is
now uh officially over i would just like
to show you uh who uh won what place and
who qualified for the candidates
tournament because as you know two
players from this tournament will
qualify for the candidates tournament so
if you guys don't want any spoilers you
know skip some 20 seconds of the video
because now i will uh show what um uh
what's been happening that's the wrong
uh that's the wrong one those are the
live ones let me just
load that up real quickly there we go uh
so after all has been done and said uh
these are the the final standings or
rather these are the the top six people
uh so uh uh already
and fabiana corona have qualified for
the 2022 candidates tournament as you
can see fabiano is tied with the grigori
operin for uh second place but uh he has
a better tiebreaker and
that's what he got into the candidates
tournament a lot of people were very
very close and a lot of people could
have been on seven and a half points if
you guys have been following the action
up until the very end um david howell
played against the vincent kaimer some i
don't know maybe 80 moves a game and it
was uh it was a draw for for the last uh
four hours the the game lasted like
seven and a half hours the the
commentators left they ended the stream
before that game finished because uh
well they just couldn't take it anymore
it was taking too long but in the end
they settled for a draw but hal really
tried to to put for something there uh
but yeah that being said now you know
you guys know who the uh two candidates
are from this features.com grand swiss
um uh of course fabi and alireza and
they will be joining the other known
candidates sergey karyakin uh young
and of course the loser of the world
championship match between carlson and
nipomishi
those are the six that are known now and
two will be decided uh uh in the feed
grand prix in the in 2022
so now we've been informed let's check
out this uh five queen game so
girlfriend with the white pieces opens
with d4
uh we have d5 by move session c4c6 sorry
about that
and knight to f3 so nothing out of the
ordinary here knight to f6 and knight to
c3 and here we have d captures on c4 so
uh grabbing that pawn we are in the slav
defense we have e for now preparing e5
and black defends the pawn with b5 so
now you can play bishop captures on c4
we have bishop to e2 and now e6 uh we
have a for now challenging this um
pawn chain and now we advance the pawn
to b4 so this is all been played before
nothing new here and you don't want to
move the knight you want to attack your
opponent's knight so e5 attacking the
knight on f6 b captures on c3 e captures
on f6 c captures on b2 and now f
captures on g7 so a true capture fest
here b captures on a1 uh promoting to a
queen and g captures on h8 promoting to
a queen so already there are four queens
on the board uh and we have queen to a5
check this is the only good move for
black and black of course plays it as
this is a known position uh and now uh
there is a game where king to f1 was
played but that's not really a good move
because after some like queen to c3 it
will be very hard for for white to play
this game uh so
you you could you know try some other
things but uh
best is what was actually played in the
game so knight to d2 just blocking check
this way and now c3 attacking the knight
here and you can't really move the
knight it seems like you could fork the
two queens uh how often do you get to
say that when you know analyzing a chess
game for the two queens uh and uh but
the problem is black has c2 opening up a
discovery here attacking the queen on d1
and here we have three queens that are
actually hanging in incredible
and after some like queen to d2 we're
gonna play queen capture sunday to with
check king captures as uh you know we
want to keep attacking the queen and we
want to open up
this back rank for the rook and now
queen to b1 it will be incredibly
difficult for white to play this for
example uh knight to c5 we're gonna play
knight to d7 and now after some like
knight captures bishop captures this is
now you know uh very very difficult for
for why the dead king is in the middle
of the board upon here is a monster and
it's not going to be easy
but okay after c3 of course you don't go
knight b3 here in the game castles was
played so we give up the knight here
pawn capture sandy bishop captures now
we trade a pair of queens also you know
a funny thing to say rook after sunday
one with the black queen still being
attacked and now we have queen captures
on a4 and this maybe is not the most
impressive way to continue this with
black so you're basically
saying uh
uh do i want to exchange this pawn for
this pawn and then i get to push my a
pawn to bring another queen into game
but white will also push his h pawn to
bring another queen into the game or do
i want to play some like queen f5 guard
this spawn and you know stop the all
this queen madness but okay in the game
queen captures an a4 was played we have
queen captures on h7 and now a5 black
starts pushing on the queen side and
white starts pushing on the king side so
obviously four queens are simply not
enough for one chess game uh and now uh
you could go for something like uh
bishop to a6 but then bishop to h5 is
very very annoying so instead of this
bishop to a6 black first plays rook to
a7 now the f7 pawn is guarded and you
you can play bishop to a6 next so here
we have h5 white continues pushing the
pawn and now bishop to a6 we have bishop
to f3 now of course not allowing this
trade and rook to d7 now putting
pressure on the d4 pawn but that's a lot
of moves and the white is uh still
pushing on the king side and you you've
stopped pushing on the queen side so
here we have pawn to h6 uh if this was
uh
a normal game maybe a move like bishop
to e3 can also be played but this is a
game where we already had four queens on
the board so naturally gelfand wants to
have another one so he pushes h5 uh rook
captures on d4 and now comes bishop to
h5 attacking this f7 pawn so we have to
defend it rogue back to d7 so we grabbed
the pawn and we just brought a rogue
back nothing happening here the problem
is queen to g8 now uh h7h8 is coming and
what do you play here well black played
bishop to d3 it's a very tricky maneuver
but it doesn't really work so feel free
to pause the video here and win the game
for boris while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
spectacular move as this is not an easy
one to figure out and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is uh
bishop to g5 so congratulations to
everyone who founded this you are uh you
know a spectacular player uh the problem
is uh for those of you who thought about
h7 this isn't all that impressive if
bishop captures queen captures we can
play queen to d4 and black is perfectly
fine here you don't have all that much
to worry about however after bishop to
g5 there are terrible threats in the
position just to give you an example if
black continues developing we just
capture the bishop here and after let's
say rook captures and the three queen
captures and f7 is checkmate the bishop
covers all the dark squares uh and
that's it so you have to do something
about this so we have bishop back to g6
now with a double attack on the rook on
d1 and also attacking the bishop on h5
but white had uh all this figure out in
advance we have rook to e1 uh now there
are there's too much pressure on this f7
pawn it's guarding these exponents
guarding the g6 bishop it's uh the
pressure is simply unbearable so here we
have bishop captures on h5 but now of
course uh the pawn uh goes to h7
we have queen to be for now attacking
the rook on e1 but now not even you know
worrying about this rook just giving it
up for the e6 pawn rook captures on e6 f
captures queen captures an e6 check rook
to e7 and now queen to c8 with check
king back to f7 and now queen to f5 with
check
asking the black king what do you want
to do do you want to go maybe to g7 but
going to g7 doesn't really work because
bishop to f6 check and it's a game over
there's really not much you can do here
after king to f7 bishop c3 check
wins the queen gets another queen into
the game there's uh no playing this and
king to h6 isn't really uh any better
because we just bring the queen into the
game and that's it rook h7 uh and a
queen captures on h7 with checkmate so
instead after this queen to f5 check
black repeated king to e8 we have queen
to see it with checking to f7 and queen
to f5 would check so it seems like a
repetition but of course boris will not
be
repeating one more time and now brings a
fifth queen into the game so queen to h8
and now we have rook to e1 check king to
h2 and now bishop to g4 there's really
not much you can do against two queens
but you have to try uh and now you are
you know free to do whatever you want
here you the the king is pretty much uh
you know
naked here in the middle of the board
there is nothing for him to do there and
the queens will now pile up on him queen
to g6 check king to d7 queen to f7 with
check now if you go to see it it's you
know just queen captures captures and
captures this is all over for black so
instead we have bishop to e7 blocking
but now uh queen uh goes to e8 to
deliver a check uh king to c7 and now
bishop captures an e7 and he was in this
position on move 37 that sergey mosses
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
so really really an impressive game by
by boris but of course you always need
two players to to create a masterpiece
such as this one so very very impressive
you know five queens in a chess game
that's something uh you know you'd
expect from an aliahin game
uh but yeah uh for uh for those of you
who are interested once again here are
the final standings of the uh of the
tournament uh furuja and karwana are
qualified for the candidates tournament
and it's going to be very very
impressive will fabi be looking for his
uh bonds back after losing to magnus in
london or will we have maybe alireza as
the next challenger to maybe magnus
maybe nepo or some of the other players
we'll see but you know chess is you know
definitely uh in a good place
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
sazan faiz alessandro atura tom darrell
michael kennedy and the david kimura for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the uh not the
coverage of this event but i will you
know come through some games to see if
there are some gems that we've missed uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day